[Music]
[Applause]
here's the deal I love bookstores you
know that about me oh don't ever do it
that's the polyp talk yeah yeah when I
would a bookstore I love looking through
the bargain bins to see the coffee table
books that nobody bought the ones that
just tanked yeah nobody wanted them you
can get them for nothing well I bought
up a whole bunch of them over the last
week we've collected the biggest duds I
want to share them with you right now
here's a coffee table book this cover
tale book is called this summer's least
popular vacation spots there's dr. e
wood right there yeah and then over here
you got madame tussauds leftover wax
clusters interesting and then
pittsburgh's here's a book I think I
know why this book didn't sell I think I
know why it wasn't popular dogs that
don't know they're being walked right
back to the pound
look you didn't even need the leash he's
like we're we go and look at that that's
just why is that little girl doing it I
don't know just no room in the house
here's a book a copy of a book that just
didn't sell it's called fox news anchor
or porn star you very hard to know I
don't know looks a keeper right here
this one well I don't know what to say
about this one's called
the big book of guys who are probably
from San Diego
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah
I'm sure there's someone here from San
Diego who can relate to this book all
right now or is made angry by it yeah or
angry yeah okay here's a book just
didn't sell what's called is Ricky going
number two that's right it's photos in
which Rick Santorum may be defecating
[Applause]
about more amore
but yeah I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
yeah and that's just all right and look
at this oh this you know off of the news
event sure sure let's go even more
deplorable big game hunting dentists
these guys are even yes yes that symbol
I think that Simba that's Simba right
there Laurel Simba
look at this dentist look Wow why - why
and then look at this and then finally
this one should sell it really should
it's called Donald Trump's mouth
[Applause]
here it is
yeah you'll huge and then of course this
one seems about
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]